no question about it you're either male
or female and it's absolutely clear hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
sex really is binaries no question about
it you're either male or female and it's
absolutely clear you could do it on
gamete size you can do it on chromosomes
to me as a biologist distinctly weird
people can simply declare I am a woman
though I have a penis Helen what do you
think lies behind this odd Distortion of
reality I would say that when I started
to write about it first I quickly
realized that this wasn't treated the
same way as anything else like just
asking very obvious questions like um
don't you think that if we allow people
to self-identify their sex this will
lead to for example destroying women
sports or putting rapists in women's
jails people would turn this back on me
and say you think that trans people are
predators you're a bigot what we were
talking about here was an intensely
linguistic movement there isn't a sense
in which a man can become a woman except
linguistically like yes okay he can have
operations most trans people don't have
any operations don't take any medicine
but that doesn't change your sex